welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of obi-wan
kenobi episode three in which darth
vader proves himself the worst parade
grand marshal let us break down this
episode scene by scene for all of the
star wars connections and visual details
that you might have missed the reminder
that the best way to support a sierra
new rockstar rockstars to get your hands
on our new latest obsession shirt
inspired by obi-wan kenobi empire's most
wanted over at newrockstarsmerch.com
when you grab that one it gives you the
added option to ride in a custom shout
out that will be in our obi-wan kenobi
after shows wikileaks the episode opens
with this tilt-up shot of obi-wan and
the transport the camera movement in the
diagonal light cast on that slanted wall
ahead forms a parallel movement and shot
composition to the opening shot of the
mustafar castle which also forms a
triangular shape it's just a really cool
way of showing these two characters
linked by the force now fully aware of
each other their collision inevitable
he's coming master here obi-wan is once
again calling out to master qui-gon but
he's only met by silence and painful
voices from his past riva telling him
that anakin is alive yoda's saying only
pain brother you find his warning to
obi-wan before showing him the security
tapes of anakin killing the younglings
qui-gon making him promise to train this
boy and his dying breath some phantom
menace and all that [ __ ] talk anakin
said to him before their duel on
mustafar and under all of this we see
vader being assembled into his suit
clamps removing his breathing tubes
first and then all the other parts and
then finally his breathing apparatus
last meaning vader has to hold his
breath for all of this while his lungs
burn every morning now we got glimpses
of this assembly at the end of revenge
of the sith but this montage more
clearly shows what obi-wan's force ghost
tells luke in return of the jedi he is
more machine now than man and you can
see how his control box has these prods
deep enough to poke into his abdomen
flesh one thing we don't see here is how
this suit and helmet all have needles
that actually dig into vader's skin to
fuse with his tissue and as the iconic
mask lowers we hear this little whistle
sound effect
yes this is the same airlock seal sound
effect from vader's first mechanized
breath in revenge of the sith
and you'll notice how the mask's
forehead has now been extended just a
bit lower this is to better match the
look of the mask design in the original
1977 star wars a lot of these movies if
you look closely at vader's helmet and
mask little details about his mask and
his armor changed just a little bit in
this case it's the closest to what we
saw in the original film and you'll
notice his mask eyepieces are reflected
these red lights at first i thought it
was the red display of the interior of
the mask but actually it's the floor
lights before him in this chamber but
the effect is the same because it
foretells the red lightsaber he will use
on his old master at the end of this
episode this opening shot shows the red
glow of the saber in his eyes the last
shot we see of in this episode we'll
show the flames of his anger so we go
from order this clean red lightsaber
shape to chaos violent flames vader's
rejuvenation chamber and most of our
castle look just as they do in rogue one
the lava cascade in the twin spire
castle that lucasfilms doug chang based
on original ralph mcquarrie art making
it look like in his words a tuning fork
for the dark side of the force the 2017
darth vader comics by charles soul show
how vader constructed this castle
deliberately at the nexus of dark side
energy in hopes of opening a portal so
he could be with padme once more but of
course he failed in this endeavor and
afterwards sealed himself away in
solitude and i love this the wide shot
of his throne room actually looks like
vader's mask in extreme close-up the two
angry red slits for the eyes vader's
throne forming the nose piece and the
steps forming his trapezoidal mouthpiece
here vader and the third sister reeva
chat he will pay for the grand
inquisitor the grand inquisitor means
nothing
kenobi is all that matters now yes james
earl jones is credited for vader's voice
here but actually if you look closely
later in the credits is the voice ai
company rhys feature this is the company
that recreated the voice of mark hamill
for luke and the disney plus shows even
though mark campbell was credited in
those two because they are using these
actors vocal likeness but by using rhys
feature here that is why vader's voice
sounds as clean as it did in the
original trilogy and yeah you may have
noticed that before vader cut her off
riva was totally blaming obi-wan for
stabbing the grain inquisitor on daiyu
this shows that she doesn't want vader
and the other inquisitors to know that
she actively usurped authority and in
doing so she makes out kenobi to be a
more lethal threat than he actually is
right now i think especially after vader
duels that lightweight old man kenobi he
probably knows that riva was the one who
stabbed the grand inquisitor by the way
no update on the status of the grand
inquisitor presumably he will recover
with some finic-shan-style stomach gears
to maintain continuity with rebels i
just think it would be really weird for
star wars to retcon him for marbles
either way it's clear darth vader
doesn't really care about the health and
well-being of the grain inquisitor as we
saw these two had a very bitter rivalry
in those 2017 comics leia asks so we
want to use a force to make the ship go
faster but he says that's not how it
works echoing han solo's line to finn
and force awakens we'll use the force
that's not how the force works
but he elaborates have you ever been
afraid of the dark
how does it feel when you turn on the
light
i feel safe
yes it feels like that it's an
interesting metaphor the force as a
literal illumination giving certainty to
a world of doubt but the way ewen
delivers this line you can tell that he
hasn't felt that safety in years this is
an interesting deeper theme of this
episode what is the path is the path the
illuminated one or is the path in shadow
illumination versus blindness actually
later this episode notice how obi-wan
will use his lightsaber as a literal
light source but doing so only blinds
him from seeing the threat light may be
his safety blanket but ultimately it is
his folly they arrive at mapuzo which is
an obscure mid-range planet mentioned as
the side of the mapuzo break-in and the
alliance intelligence reports that are
connected with the star wars
role-playing game in the 90s here we
learn this planet has been mined
stripped of ventrium by the empire
ventrium is mineral that was mentioned
in the star wars clone adventures game
as a d-board you'll notice a red r5
astromech unit maybe the same one who
keeps reappearing in mandalorian and
book bubba fed on tatooine the one with
the busted motivator from a new hope if
so this aftermath is racking up some
serious mileage maybe it's just a
different astromech obi-wan spots an
apparition of anakin hayden christensen
is unburned wearing brown jedi robes
deborah chow distorts this close-up of
ewin but only shoots hayden at a
distance and it's just kind of creepy
like we're not meant to connect with or
empathize with vader or anakin in this
moment he's not the human point of view
here he's really meant to be shown from
afar as a devilish ghost a mirage that's
driving obi-wan insane meanwhile the
inquisitor ship approaches the fortress
inquisitorius on the ocean moon of nir
we actually visit the same location in
the jedi fallen order game it is the
home base of the inquisitors where they
relocated after they had a base on
coruscant called the works nur is
actually not that far away from mustafar
you'll notice on the deck is an imperial
lambda class shuttle and tie fighters
hang like bats from the ceiling which
definitely give this hanger a cave-like
quality making it especially sinister as
the third sister marches past every
stormtrooper an imperial officer halts
in attention to show her respect riva
enters the inquisitor chamber framed
directly between the points of the head
chair that chair shape meant to match
their ship and vader's castle and this
places riva directly between the prongs
of the dark side tuning fork and then
here is the creepiest detail of this
episode the room is lined with this red
shelf that not only visually parallels
vader's thin red window but if you look
closely at that shelf you can see
lightsabers and domed young lean helmets
on display as trophies sickening
assuming riva was one of those runaway
younglings these might belong to her
friends or maybe to herself the fifth
brother uses the force on reba i
am the next in line we still don't
really have a sense of the numerical
designations of the inquisitors fifth
brother versus third sister the numbers
clearly do not correspond to their rank
and the ocean depths behind them the sea
life includes the blue vent glider
that's the large shark sized neural
aquatic species they swim past in fall
in order obi-wan and leia get a ride
from this transport driven by frack
voiced by zac braff his snout pants open
like that of a star-nosed mole leia uses
the alias of voluma which in disney's
galaxy's edge is the name of a lost
touca cat mentioned on the notice board
in ogus cantina she says father aren't
you going to say hello
hello oh you were one there away from
the line say the line ben hello there
yay
obi-wan passes freck's imperial cigna
and if you look closely you can see
frack has actually hand-painted it so
frick himself did some arts and crafts
painting this banner himself to show his
allegiance as opposed to him being
handed a printed banner that he has to
like reluctantly put on his transport no
this guy is a true believer now one of
the stormtroopers who they meet is
played by an old pal of me and tommy's
from the la comedy scene shane hartline
oh no we'll find him we always do
congrats shane for booking this you did
it buddy obi-wan accidentally uses
leia's real name and they smarter than
usual stormtroopers immediately pick up
on it but obi-wan covers by saying leia
was her mother's name sometimes when i
look at luma
i see her mother's face yes again
obi-wan invokes padme this series giving
us several reminders of the bond that he
felt toward her losing padme was as hard
for him as losing anakin in a lot of
ways obi-wan again does that beard
stroke gesture a move that you and
mirrored from alec guinness from the
1977 film and he first did in the
revenge of the sith final scene in order
to show his aging into that era of the
character as they lead the stormtroopers
chat
yes the t-16s are the sky hopper ships
that luke will later pilot and the model
version obi-wan tried to give luke as a
toy in episode one the stormtroopers
casually chatting about it it's kind of
a recurring thing in star wars like we
heard the death star stormtroopers
chatting in a new hope talking about the
vt-16 or bt-16
and in the mandalorian season one
chapter eight the stormtroopers outside
navarro talked about it too
obi-wan explains to leia this jedi were
taken from our families when we're very
young i still have glimpses flashes
really my mother's shawl my father's
hands
i remember a baby yes i think i had a
brother
i really don't remember him i wished i
did then i joined the jedi and i got a
new family just like you so the little
we knew of obi-wan before this is that
he was born on a planet called stoo-jon
a planet actually named after jon
stewart and he was taken to coruscant
when he was less than six months old he
was a babe so the baby brother that
obi-wan remembered would logically be
older than he is but who knows if we
will meet brother kenobi or if he's
force sensitive personally i'm okay
never meeting the guy frax sells out
obi-wan and leia and as that probe droid
id's him obi-wan uses his so uncivilized
blaster to destroy it and take out the
storm troopers one stroke trooper falls
on the laser fence and gets the maul
treatment gouch and then the last one
kenobi shoots from a low angle without
sighting it so smooth but that blast
does come in just inches above leia's
head now it can be hard to see the
deeper truth of this it can also be hard
to see the light at the end of the
tunnel when you have high interest debt
and sometimes it can be even harder to
ask for help that's where upstart comes
in upstart powered personal loans can
help you pay down high interest debt all
online with simple and easy to
understand payment terms upstart has
helped over 1.8 million customers on
their path to financial freedom whether
it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses upstart can
help you get one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date upstart knows
that you are more than just your credit
score so rather than looking at your
credit score alone upstart's model
considers other factors like your income
your employment and other information
provided in your loan application to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
you can check your rate in minutes for
loans between 1 000 and 50 000 without
impacting your credit score you can even
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan so don't
wait and check your rate today at
upstart.com new rockstars at
substart.com new rockstars to check your
rate today don't forget to use our url
to let them know that we sent you go to
upstart.com newrockstars indira varma
plays tala hajjah's contact rescuing
them disguised as an imperial officer
meanwhile the inquisitor's map table
translates to mapuzo and you'll notice
the third sister and the fifth brother
stand just on either side of that empty
grand inquisitor seat both of them
wanting it but as riva turns to leave
she is once again framed between the two
prongs the tuning forks seat back inside
the mapuzo droid maintenance shop you
can see legs of protocol droids hanging
on the walls legs for days now actually
at some point during these years of star
wars history c-3po will have his legs
swapped out for a silver one which is
why he has a random silver leg at the
beginning of a new hope also on one of
the shelves you can see the clampy hand
of a b2 battle droid from attacking the
clones and they meet the forever loyal
mining droid ned b
hey ledby
this is
l0la 59. he's just a loader they don't
allow them to communicate
but what if he has something to say yes
another example of leia's trust in
droids something that she will rely on
with r2 in a new hope tala brings them
back into this jedi safe house we have
safe houses like this throughout the
galaxy
try and link the systems
some call it the path the path so in the
high republic novels the path was the
name given by the heel for hyperspace
lanes to travel the galaxy faster than
the republic of the jedi could this path
could refer to a similar navigation
network these safe houses mirror the
american underground railroad the
network of safe houses for runaway
slaves to make their way to the free
states into canada like the jedi symbol
marked on the wall here slaves and
abolitionists would mark trees and
services on buildings to signal to each
other safe passage in just a little
detail here i appreciate how they call
it the path whereas the inquisitors call
it the trail something you embark upon
versus something that you follow tala
continues to explain it all leads to
jabim
from there we give them new identities
and get them out so jabim is a planet
originally from the non-canon republic
comics later in the empire comics it's
just a muddy rain-soaked mining planet
that joined the separatists during the
clone wars and will later be the setting
of a rebels versus empire conflict
during the galactic civil war between
mapuzo and jabim this path seems to be
linked with mining planets and the
equipment and minerals that are shipped
among them perhaps crate from the last
jedi could have been part of this path
which would explain why there was an old
abandoned rebel base there tala says
these days the empire hunts anyone who's
force sensitive
even children
what happens to them
we're not sure
no one ever sees them again yeah sounds
like the emperor's project harvester or
some version of it might be back in
effect remember that was his clone wars
plot to have cad bane kidnap force
sensitive babies for a future sith army
these force sensitive youths tracked via
a holocron in the 2017 comics shokostanu
returns to the jedi temple to uncover a
holocron to try to rebuild the jedi
order this is a holocron that palpatine
tells vader to recover with jocasta
still alive but vader kills jocasta and
crushes that holocron revealing that he
actually does not want more inquisitors
to have to work with just to give you a
sense of what vader thinks of these guys
you'll notice this safe house has been
marked by various other jedi which in my
opinion is not very smart to leave any
trace if you don't want the empire to
track you but you know i get it i was
able to make out a few of these there's
roganda ismarin who was an alderaanian
jedi initiate who survived the purge
who's a legends figure from the 1995
children of the jedi novel valon halcyon
aka hal horn secret son of the jedi neya
halcyon from the 1996 x-wing rogue
squadron comics also a legends figure a
purge survivor who became a karelian
security force officer and inspector
later became father to corrinhorn and
jyn altus a jedi master from the legends
2009 clone wars no prisoners novels head
of the artesian jedi who do not follow
the jedi high council but still serve
the republic and obi-wan finds among
these a message from quinlan referring
to quinlan vos now master boss no
relation he forgot an s this was a
character who was first inspired by a
background hooded figure on tatooine and
phantom menace later given a fuller
backstory in the republic comics and
planned to appear in revenge of the sith
on kashyyyk but his role was reduced to
just a quick mention master vos has
moved his troops to boss pity quinlan
appeared in an episode of clone wars and
was planned to have a much bigger arc in
clone wars before the show was cancelled
but that storyline became the basis of
the 2015 novel dark disciple where he
was love interest of dooku's one-time
apprentice asajj ventress now quinlan
was always suggested to have survived
order 66. his name appeared alongside
jedi survivors and that the inquisitors
were hunting during those 2017 darth
vader comics and then later in those
comics he was mentioned by farron barr
now it is confirmed that quinlan is
alive still smuggling young lands to
safety actually he may be the one to
have saved grogu from the jedi temple
and now i am wondering if this could be
the character played by o'shea jackson
jr maybe we'll find out next week
obi-wan reads his message only when the
eyes are closed
can you truly see
see what
the way a cryptic line but yes it is a
recurring theme for jedi to mask their
physical vision to make them more in
touch with the force like luke lowering
his targeting display kanan losing his
eyesight but also invokes the theme of
blindness vs illumination in this
episode obi-wan sees the force as the
light that saves him from his fear of
darkness but quinlan is now telling him
that he must embrace uncertainty to see
the way perhaps a way to a reunion with
qui-gon now like the mention of the path
this episode closed captioning
capitalizes way capital w which could be
a clue for what this actually is now
quinlan is known for psychometry the
jedi skill of understanding someone's
past through an object that they touched
or possessed like what we saw with rey
and luke's lightsaber and force awakens
so quinlan could be hinting at his own
abilities here but the capital w way
could also refer to this is the way the
way of the watch the mandalorian cult of
the armor in the young din jaren in
wikileaks i go to a
pretty reachy theory about how i think
those two could be connected but obi-wan
gets the dizzies again as vader arrives
in this camp
yeah just his breathing and his shadow
are enough to scare the crap out of us
as obi-wan peers out at him notice the
moment obi-wan winces ever so slightly
and that is the moment vader stops and
senses him and vader now knowing obi-wan
is near uses the same cruel tactic that
riva used attacking innocent bystanders
to draw out the jedi's itchy savior
instinct he force chokes one man and
then when his son comes out to help him
he shoves that kid and snaps his neck
then he drags a screaming woman behind
him in the dirt remember vader will also
use this tactic to torture han in order
to lure luke to cloud city and empire
the tactic works here too vader is about
to kill a hiding couple a little hiding
anakin and padme until obi-wan appears
in his periphery and flees to a nearby
quarry vader follows appearing before
him and notice how obi-wan's jog slows
to a halt reminding us of old man
obi-wan's slow approach to vader in the
quarter of the death star a new hope i
love the shock composition of massive
vader in the foreground the red
lightsaber pinning him into the frame
whereas before anakin was in the far
distance very small in frame now it is
vader who is looming large and obi-wan
itty-bitty in frame obi-wan ignites his
blade finally but not to engage vader at
first instead to just use it as a torch
in the darkness but instead he is
blinded by its light and vader reappears
what have you become
i am
what you made me now while that reese
feature technology reproduced james earl
jones voice they likely still had hayden
deliver these lines on set and for this
line it definitely sounds like they
mixed in a bit of hayden's voice just
like how they mixed matt lanter anakin's
voice with james earl jones voice in the
scene in rebels when ahsoka broke open
his mask then you will die
here it underscores the personal history
between ewan's character and hayden's
character from revenge of the sith
obi-wan then gets surprised from the
side just as vader jumped out at luke in
their cloud city dueling empire and
notice how while obi-wan clutches his
saber hilt dispensably with two hands
vader is able to confidently strike with
just one hand clearly showing how rusty
obi-wan really is the ears have made you
weak obi-wan's able to briefly escape by
swiping a conduit to release some smoke
similar to how luke slips vader by
releasing steam and empire meanwhile
riva finds a safe house and rages when
she sees the jedi symbol another
possible hint that she might have been
that jedi young lane in the temple now
particularly triggered by jedi
iconography but notice how riva does not
follow the path to catch leia she just
deduces where the path leads and skips
right to the destination because as a
former jedi she knows the path she knows
where the path leads she's not going to
follow the way anymore or the grand
inquisitor's trail instead she blazes
her own way and as usual by taking her
own risks she's able to stay one step
ahead of her prey vader knocks over a
vat of ventrium and he force chokes
obi-wan until the old man drops his
saber and vader ignites this mineral to
literally rake obi-wan across the coals
scalding his flesh just like how obi-wan
left anakin burning alive on mustafar
therefore the light that obi-wan once
viewed as the force comforted him is now
a source of pain your pain
has just begun
maybe it's just the way ewin screams
here but his streaks sounds a lot like
anakin's pain screams when he was burned
[Music]
now these two brothers are reconnecting
through that same pain but he force
pushes obi-wan out of these flames
signaling that he doesn't want him to
die here he just wants to torture him in
future scarier ways but tala manages to
reignite those minerals to form a
barrier where ned b can carry over one
to safety i just love the shots of vader
with the flames behind him those flames
reflected in his eyepieces creating the
illusion of a fire blazing from within
his helmet as if underneath all this
armor this is still a man on fire the
flames from the lava of mustafar are
never able to be extinguished that's all
the cool stuff i found in this episode
again support new rockstars by checking
out our great merch options over at new
rockstars merch.com you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at avos following
the rockstar subscribe to rockstars more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you